[MUSIC PLAYING]
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Hi,
I'm Wayne Piekarkski
and I'm here today at
the assistant sandbox
area of Google I/O 2019.
And we're in the
smart home area.
And I have Carl Vogel here
from the product team.
And what we're going to
be talking about today
is smart home and
what it means and what
it means for developers.
So Carl, what is
the developer story?
And what is smart
home all about?
CARL VOGEL: Smart home
is a way for users
to control all the connected
devices in their house.
Everything from smart
lights and smart thermostats
to even smart plugs.
And even vacuum cleaners now.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: OK, cool.
So what does it
mean for developers?
Like, can anyone build
for this smart home?
CARL VOGEL: Exactly, so we
have over a 3,500 brands that
go ahead and integrate
with Google Assistant
and are growing rapidly.
Anyone can go into the
Actions on Google Console
and integrate their smart
devices into Google Assistant.
Such that users can control
them with just the Assistant
and their voice.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: OK, cool.
So this year at
Google I/O 2019, I'm
understanding we've
announced the local home SDK.
CARL VOGEL: Yeah.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: So
what's that about?
And what's new for
developers and why
are they interested in this?
CARL VOGEL: It's great.
So developers today integrate
with the Google Assistant
via the smart home API, which
is a cloud-to-cloud integration.
And cloud-to-cloud
integrations naturally
have some amount of
latency and reliability.
So we wanted to provide
a method for developers
to process those smart
home intents locally
on Google Home speakers and
Google [? NS ?] displays.
Such that we can turn on and
off the lights and other things
much faster and with
higher reliable.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: We do it
directly by skipping the cloud,
basically.
CARL VOGEL: Yeah, we skip
that developers cloud
and they can replicate their
business logic there and run it
on our devices.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: OK, well,
what excites me the most
is that here at I/O
we have this fantastic
demo that we've built.
CARL VOGEL: It's a great demo.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: So we have
this great train set here
that's designed to demonstrate
local versus cloud execution.
So I guess there's
this button here
that I really want to press.
CARL VOGEL: Give me one
second if I can, Wayne.
So what we're looking at is
this is the local network.
And this is the
internet once the query
leaves the user's home.
We have the life
of a local query
and the life of a cloud query.
So with that, go ahead
and push the button.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: So we're
going to race some trains here
that are going to go around.
And then these light
bulbs are going
to come on when they're done.
OK, here we go.
CARL VOGEL: Here we
have the user saying,
turn on the lights.
And we see these two queries
going to the Assistant server.
And they're both going to be
processed in the same way.
And being the smart home API,
they go ahead in [? event ?]
and we send that to the partner
cloud or the developer cloud
where they go ahead and
process that intent,
and ultimately then fulfill it.
If we know the device
is locally controllable,
then we'll send that
command back down
to the Google Home device,
where we'll then pull up
the developers' JavaScript
to process that intent where
they can communicate
with their light.
And look, turn it on.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
That one's done.
This one's still
coming by the cloud.
CARL VOGEL: Yeah,
it's still coming in,
it's going to get there.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
And there we go.
CARL VOGEL: Yeah.
So what this does, again,
highlights the reduce latency
that we can get with the local
home SDK and local operations.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
This is awesome.
I really love this train set.
I've always loved trains
since I was a kid.
So this is a really fun demo.
So where can developers
go to learn more
about the local home SDK?
CARL VOGEL: Yeah,
g.co/localhomeSDK is
our landing page.
We also are giving
a talk Wednesday
at 5:30 PM called Local
Technologies for the Smart
Home.
So if you're interested,
check it out and learn more.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: And it's
also on YouTube as well.
So people can check
that out, too, later on.
CARL VOGEL: Exactly,
[INAUDIBLE]..
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Awesome.
Well, thanks for
your time, Carl.
CARL VOGEL: Yeah, thanks, Wayne.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: And thanks
for watching the video.
This was the Assistant
sandbox area.
So we'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]